o cine'eco é um stival internacional de
cinema de ambiente em que se realiza a
ensaia desde 1995 é um stival que de
certo modo pioneiro na sede do projeto
lançar em 1994 de um concurso nacional
do vídeo inspirado sobretudo né não
tínhamos popular para a preservação do
ambiente e da paisagem só está no parque
natural da serra da estrela tem mais
reserva biogenética a que importa
preservar e com que o espírito
empreendedor
apresentei essa proposta o município
saia na altura de fazer um concurso
nacional foi baixo subiu depois
iniciamos a nossa viagem de 25 anos até
hoje lançando definitivamente um
festival internacional cinema ambiente
em si na altura falar do ambiente era
falar da natureza como eu costumo dizer
dos pássaros das árvores é e também uma
uma visão muito minimalista é muitas
vezes também com algum muralista maio
hoje passados estes anos vemos
efetivamente todo este percurso toda
esta trajetória que tem sido seguida e
que não é é muito relevante e esta
trajetória de 25 anos tem sido uma
trajetória que nós reputamos de muito
importante
procuramos trazer essa ideia é enfim
várias personalidades que nós achamos
que são importantes no contexto do das
temáticas que são abordadas e procuramos
sobretudo trabalhar para o público em
geral porque 95 era difícil é chamar a
atenção dos públicos para as questões do
ambiente hoje com esta trajetória com
todas estas preocupações que temos temos
conquistado digamos assim o público para
o cinema de ambiente porque entendemos
que o cinema é uma ferramenta importante
para chamar a atenção
do grande público e depois também é
temos é uma outra numa outra vertente
tem a ver com um o facto de nós
procurarmos salvar o o o futebol para é
o público escolar e com isso também é
cumprirmos 11 um serviço público que
achamos que é muito importante aqui é é
o serviço educativo junto das escolas do
país é onde se inclui também muitas
universidades
o futebol tem todos os anos várias
convidadas várias partes do mundo que
nos trazem visões diferenciadoras e que
nos trazem também portanto é muito
normal a para o festival porque lhes
permita pôr um lado ver filmes
ambientais sonho convidado a ser todos
os anos a melhor produção de cinema de
ambiente que temos ensaia concorrem
cerca de 500 a 600 filmes por ano dos
quais são os relacionados entre 80 e 100
filmes e e isso para mim porque depois
com a presença do realizador de
diretores seleção de aulas com o público
antes e depois negociamos para tirar
partido digamos assim
tudo isso são personalidades como eu
digo de todo mundo que nós convidamos e
que de algum modo também é é
significativo para a expressão do
próprio festival
mas se o futebol tem uma componente
forte digamos assim do ponto de vista da
sua internacionalização
tem também uma componente forte do ponto
vista da ligação à comunidade porque nós
nomeamos todos os anos 30 personalidades
locais para patrocinarem longas
internacionais o que é que isso permite
me desloco
é com que o festival se próximo da
comunidade porque envolve a comunidade
na dinâmica do próprio festival e para
mim também levar cada vez mais público a
sala de cinema público o cinema de
ambiente e portanto esta é uma
iniciativa que nós temos organizado nos
últimos anos e que está enredado só
entre os contributos para o hospital
outra componente que nós chamamos que é
muito importante tem a ver com o fato de
nós termos várias secções competitivas
do festival curtas e longas
internacionais curtas e longas de língua
portuguesa e também um panorama regional
a vários prêmios
digamos assim a disputa mas nós achamos
que é componente dan no panorama
regional é importante porque permite
algum modo um algum modo a dar a
oportunidade os jovens e as pessoas
daquela região poderem fazer é e
apresentarem os seus trabalhos
relativamente à temática do dom salvo da
denunciante que estavam a concurso há
uma imensidão de temáticas como devem
imaginar campeã no ano alargar o
espectro digamos assim deve ser cuidado
como há pouco dizia se a 95 falar de
ambienta era falar um pouco numa versão
muito minimalista é muito relativamente
às questões da paisagem hoje como deve
imaginar o leque e tudo hoje quase em
ambiente desde a questão e com foco
sobretudo às alterações climáticas que
hoje se verificam e que nos devem nos
envolvem cada vez mais a todos porque é
o sinepe tem essa preocupação é ensinado
depois há todo um conjunto de outras
temáticas como seja automática dos
juízos dos mares do rio dos oceanos
do agronegócio toda a questão que tem a
ver também com os nossos hábitos de vida
saudável portanto como se costuma dizer
hoje quase tudo eu tenho a ver com a
questão do ambiente e isso é muito
importante e que está presente nas
abordagens cinematográficas porque hoje
é possível num filme apresentarmos um
problema
contamos uma história e apresentarmos
uma função
hoje o cinema de ambiente já é muito
mais apelativo já chega mais facilmente
as massas digamos assim porque no início
da nossa trajetória o festival a
robotização muito para públicos mais
segmentados digamos assim
e nestes anos tem sido feito essa
trajetória de alargamento digamos assim
os públicos porque há também uma
evolução muito grande quer tecnológica
do ponto de vista da tecnologia
associados audiovisuais quer também
daquilo que tem a ver depois com as
abordagens com o lado artístico digamos
assim do cinema de ambiente enquanto
objecto artístico e isso tem sido um ano
levanta intensivo é é muito encorajador
porque também desperta nas pessoas
o entusiasmo ea curiosidade de ver
cinema de ambiente a numa altura
qualquer do ano mas sobretudo neste
festival de cinema como eu disse decorre
anualmente a ensaia em outubro durante
uma semana num concentrado muito grande
atividade e portanto am nesta matéria
também vos posso dizer que o estival é
para além destas temáticas todas que
estão associadas têm uma outra
componente que nós achamos relevante que
é o fato de convidarmos todos os anos
personalidade é que ajudam digamos assim
promover o próprio festival o todos os
anos nós convidamos artistas
atores e atrizes é que de algum modo
ajudam é promover a visibilidade do do
festival e da própria cidade de saia
enquanto destino turístico portanto há
aqui uma aposta do município neste caso
um da cultura no ambiente no turismo
como fator também em desenvolvimento
isso é relevante para nós do nosso ponto
de vista porque também é cumprir esse é
essa missão
digamos assim de promoção turística vi
uma cidade do interior do país que
procura afirmar-se também no campo é
cultural
damos das outras atividades são também
relevantes porque são também vários
porque o festival para além da sua da
parte competitiva está em conjunto as
atividades paralelas que desenvolve ao
longo da semana
desde conferências workshops concertos
exposições é é pra nós é é é um conjunto
de atividades que desenvolvemos é muito
importante porque né relevante poder
depois de conseguir mais envolvência dos
públicos nesta nesta nesta área
uma das iniciativas que reputamos muito
importante é a organização anual de um
grande time um grande uma grande
conferência internacional porque pra mim
traseiras aia/an gente todo mundo o ano
passado organizamos o 1º fórum
internacional de ti vai cinema de
ambiente
conseguimos ter ensaia 35 diretores do
festival de cinema de ambiente de todo
mundo e fizemos saiu foco digamos assim
do cinema do ambiente foram discutidas
todas as questões que têm a ver com o
ambiente isso é muito relevante
lideramos este processo tal modo creio
que estamos lançados no segundo fórum
como estamos lançados noutros projectos
de grande dimensão internacional da
própria organização
dando ao ou jeff am que é um prémio da
rede green filme atuar que é uma rede de
39 estivais cinema de ambiente do qual
nós somos um dador vivo que eu também
sou membro da direcção tem pra me
permite mais uma afirmação do festival
ou seja cada um desses 39 estivais
indica o uma longa e uma curta para
depois uma espécie de óscares para os
marcianos do ambiente convenceram ambos
assim premiados
depois deste prémio ter sido recebido em
priscos estival de paris encerrou sá na
república dominicana em toronto no
canadá e também nos estados unidos em
san francisco
este ano saíram recebe esse prêmio
digamos assim o prémio do melhor filme
do mundo para a área do ambiente volta
condessa da indicação da nomeação de
filmes por parte dos 39 diretores do
festival de cinema de ambiente
essa é uma componente da afirmação forte
do do festival tapar como eu dizia da
afirmação do carro juntamente com os
atores no caixa e câmera que nós
envolvemos no no festival e depois há
uma afirmação nacional e porque é uma
afirmação nacional porque o festival do
corta todo ano em mais de 30 cidades do
país
senna ex apresenta em 30 cidades em
vários locais de lisboa através de
vários interlocutores que temos na
grande área metropolitana do porto
através de um parceiro l porte pequeno
swell digamos assim um festival a os
várias as várias cidades da área
metropolitana do porto mas em coimbra em
quatro ilhas dos açores são miguel faial
terceira são jorge ainda também na
madeira mexe em muitas outras cidades
nos 15 conselhos da comunidade
intermunicipal das beiras de serra da
estrela e ii e isso faz com que essa
afirmação do festival no país seja muito
importante e depois
associadas à universidade estamos
presentes na universidade de coimbra
também com as tensões que nos são
solicitadas na universidade do porto com
o sempre com uma semana na na reitoria
da universidade do porto com filmes cine
eco do ponto de vista ambiental para
permitir a discussão e também com os
alunos e todo o pessoal da universidade
na universidade da beira interior na
covilhã anotado em vila real
o instituto politécnico da guarda no
instituto politécnico de viseu entre
outras universidades onde durante o ano
como diz o festival está presente estar
aonde for solicitado porque essa é uma
forma de nós levarmos o festival junto
do público é uma forma de ajudarmos a
cumprir essa missão que nós temos em
matéria do valor ambientais que é no
fundo a largar a possibilidade de quem
tiver interesse poderá ver filmes de
temática ambiental discutimos porque é
preciso fazer muito é preciso mudar
hábitos é preciso mudar comportamentos
como nós sabemos e todas as ferramentas
são importantes nessa nessa matéria
portanto é nós achamos que isso é muito
relevante e procuramos fazer isso como
fazemos também em universidades
internacionais somos solicitados
já estivemos na universidade de brasília
por exemplo tivemos um grande fórum em
buenos aires no méxico é sobretudo em
várias cidades do brasil para me
conferências para darmos o exemplo do
sina época que eu estou a falar aqui e
falou nesses grandes fóruns
internacionais é como um exemplo daquilo
que quero é e pode ser cada vez mais é
um estival de cinema que dar contributos
para a melhoria digamos assim só para
aquilo que deve ser a melhoria dos
nossos comportamentos para um melhor
ambiente tanto é uma maneira geral era
isso que eu queria trazer assim como
também um conjunto de eventos que nós
realizamos ao longo do ano e que tem
muito ver com esta única com esta
preocupação e que tem muito a ver com
esta estratégia
que é fazer de um cd um do cinema uma
ferramenta importante é para a promoção
dos valores ambientais numa num evento
como eu disse ontem todos contamos
enquanto os espectadores enquanto
membros ativos participantes a atividade
é que nós reputamos importante e depois
há outros focos nós colocamos sobretudo
foco na comunicação a comunicação para
nós é muito importante a promoção é
porque é um é tão importante é fazer
como comunicar e nos dias de hoje isso é
importante para alargar ainda mais o
espectro das nossas mensagens das nossas
preocupações no fundo da nossa missão
tanto era isto que eu no fundo queria
trazer vos até vós hoje nesta nesta
ocasião por que lançar também este
desafio ex-técnico do fio todos porque é
preciso fazer algo porque é preciso
mudar a mente porque é preciso remar
contra a maré
porque é preciso cuidar do planeta não
há planeta b e é preciso diminuir o
consumo dos plásticos é preciso sabermos
fazer o uso de água é porque são
matérias cada vez mais premente nos
nossos dias
e por falar em água mesmo para rematar
quero dizer-vos que estivemos no ano
passado no fórum mundial da água quando
organizamos uma mostra de curtas
nacionais e internacionais sobre a
temática da água
foi um momento alto do festival ter sido
convidado para uma mostra desta natureza
e agora com muita freqüência lançamos
esse desafio quero jovens quer o público
em geral que é a possibilidade de fazer
em cada vez mais sobretudo no âmbito das
escolas curtas sobre a temática em água
porque é importante valorizar a este
recurso que é cada vez mais escasso e
que devemos preservar é toda da nossa
forma de estar no nosso dia a dia
este é no fundo é a mensagem esta é a
mensagem que cria três nervos
este um futebol que se organiza todos os
anos ensaia é normalmente deixamos o
convite para irem até saia em outubro
durante uma semana verdura arqueada
produção mundial do filme do ambiente ou
para acolherem nas vossas instituições
nas nossas escolas não gostam cimentos
sóis cine'eco e assim podermos dar cada
vez mais é um empurrão nesta matéria de
ambiente sobretudo destas preocupações
com as alterações climáticas
muito obrigado a todos
[Aplausos]